new research is shedding light on the
genetic reasons why a woman in Scotland
feels virtually no pain 71 year old Jo
Cameron is her name she also experiences
very little anxiety or fear and her body
appears to heal very quickly now
scientists say they know why it's a
mutation a mutation rather and a
previously unidentified gene Elizabeth
Palmer is in London with how the
potential breakthrough could help
millions of people who suffer from
chronic and acute pain
Elizabeth good morning to you good
morning well this medical discovery
happened like so many others by chance
it started with an alert doctor and a
highly unusual patient who refused to
have any drugs after surgery jo Cameron
has never felt pain not after wrist
surgery not when she had her hip
replaced not even giving birth to her
children things I felt my body
stretching for peculiar feelings but
nothing's made me no pain researchers at
London's University College think they
know why they found a mutation in fact a
bit missing from one of her genes that
affected Jo's body chemistry so she
simply doesn't feel what the rest of us
call pain have a look at her here in her
doctors office happily chewing chilis so
hot they make her husband weeks a pain
free life may sound great but it does
have a downside Jo often doesn't realize
when she's hurt herself I'm ironing and
quite often ice and ironing away and and
suddenly fine I've iron my arm and it's
only when I see after so sort of mark
down there there's an eye on my arm but
for doctors this is an exciting
discovery there's a vast problem of
around about six or seven percent of the
population have ongoing excruciating
pain so we really do need some new
therapies millions of patients suffering
both chronic and acute pain have to rely
at the moment on addictive drugs so we
hope that we'll be able to help people
in the future by harnessing the
knowledge that we gain from the mutation
in Jo and trying to mimic it either
through gene therapy or potentially in a
pharmacological way
now we're probably many years and many
millions of dollars away from this
translating into a treatment but it does
provide a ray of light for so many
people who spend a lot of their lives in
agony
Anthony Elizabeth Palmer in London Thank
You Liz what a mixture she described
childbirth as a quote peculiar feeling
image of her ironing her arm and feeling
no wonder sort of how she ended up on
her arm but no physical pain but also no
fear or anxiety she said it was like a
little tickle yeah you know on the
surface it sounds like that would be a
good thing to feel no pain but I think a
little bit of pain is okay a lot of
great art and music come from pain